in a recent episode of Curb Your
Enthusiasm Larry David holds up a pack
of cigarettes
specifically Morley cigarettes now let's
rewind back to 1960 and the Alfred
Hitchcock classic psycho take a look at
the cigarettes the psychiatrist is
smoking in the final scene of the film
look familiar
Morley's have appeared in hundreds of TV
shows and movies throughout the last
century in everything from the twilight
zone to Seinfeld and to be clear
Morley's are not a real cigarette brand
so what exactly is going on here is this
some deep secret connected cinematic
universe that ties Norman Bates to
George Costanza
if you pay really close attention to
shows and movies you'll start to notice
many of the same objects over and over
again like this newspaper
there are several fake brands that cross
over into other works including Acme
oceanic air and Heisler beer but one of
the most reused brands is Morley Morley
cigarettes is the most prominent brand
of fictional cigarettes that has been
used for the past 60 years in films
television shows and video games
Jonathan Koontz says they come from a
company in Sun Valley California the
Earl haze press is a 100 year old prop
house that supplies fake brand props to
Hollywood and they are the main
suppliers of Morley cigarettes according
to its website Earl haze press pretty
much sells fake everything from chips
and beer to magazines and license plates
Morley's design is based on the most
popular real cigarette brand in the
United States Marlboro with its
signature red and white packaging
[Music]
Marlboros are often nicknamed Marlies
hence the fake name Morley Earl Hays
press sells Morley's in a few different
varieties including Morley lights as you
can see here but to understand why
Morley even exists in the first place we
have to go back and take a look at the
love-hate relationship between tobacco
companies and Hollywood in the 1950s you
mostly had sponsors for TV and radio
where the advertising agencies paid for
and produced the show the characters
even used the same products and many of
these early advertisers were you guessed
it tobacco companies
I Love Lucy was famously sponsored by
Philip Morris so you would see brand
integrations like
[Music]
you'll love them they're so smooth and
mile and they taste so good movies were
also typically crossed promoted with
tobacco companies
here's Joan Crawford for example smoking
Chesterfield cigarettes and a poster
promoting her film Flamingo Road if a
show wasn't sponsored it would use a
fake brand instead since it wasn't
getting paid to show the real brand
enter Morley this fake brand can be
traced all the way back to episodes of
Perry Mason and one of the most
memorable horror movies of all time
psycho although the box shows an earlier
white design as opposed to the newer red
and white version and I think this is
what really started the Morley
cigarettes craze Morley's popped up in
TV shows like Naked City and The
Twilight Zone most famously nightmare at
20,000 feet with William Shatner
lighting up a Morley on a plane but
Morley's weren't used as much during the
1970s and 1980s why for one the 1970
public helped cigarette-smoking Act
banned cigarette ads from airing on
television and radio this was part of a
big push to stop smoking in TV shows and
the appearance of cigarettes on TV
decreased in general around this time by
about 70% tobacco companies turn to
movies instead paying big bucks to have
their cigarettes appear in popular films
throughout the eighties so there wasn't
much of a need for fake brands like
Morley in movies either but this all
changed again in 1998 with what's known
as the master settlement agreement which
banned tobacco advertising in both films
and TV paving the way for the fake
brands triumphant return
[Music]
the real explosion of Morley cigarettes
in popularity in pop culture comes at
the end of the 1990s in the x-files well
you'll be interested to know that Morley
tobacco has subpoenaed all of our files
on the case in the show the cigarette
smoking man is a villainous character
played by William Davis he famously
smoked Morley's and the fake tobacco
company was actually incorporated into
the plot in the episode called Brand X
something you couldn't do very easily
with a real brand but more on that in a
bit
following the x-files Morley started
showing up everywhere even in video
games and music videos it is literally
appeared in hundreds of movies and
television shows here's George smoking a
pack in Seinfeld and Chandler holding a
pack in an episode of Friends
there also found a justified and the
2019 Breaking Bad movie El Camino shows
technically have the freedom to show
real brands these days for historical
realism as long as it's not a paid ad
strikes
so why would they opt for a made-up
brand from the 60s well real brands are
a big risk there are several reasons why
film and TV producers would avoid using
real brand names without permission
there is a little bit of legal jeopardy
if your product is used to kill somebody
or is defamed in any way you might be
subject to lawsuits a study found that
villains are the ones who are typically
depicted smoking in films and TV and
brands likely do not want their image
associated with criminals Apple for
instance reportedly doesn't let villains
use its products and movies real
products are typically covered up or
disguised when used in shows or movies
in the 1930s and 40s the brand letters
on cars and films were carefully removed
Hollywood was quite careful to keep
brand
names out of their films they didn't
want to be associated with any
particular product line and they didn't
want offend the people that were using a
rival product so these days Morley's are
mainly used as the replacement brand an
inside-joke similar to those 555 phone
numbers in the Wilhelm scream Morley
cigarettes have become almost like a
meme on the web something where you can
kind of wink your eye at the audience
and say you know we know that you know
that this is really a movie or a
television show and we're just kind of
playing with things and just as there's
a risk associated with smoking real
cigarettes there's a risk with Morley's
as well the problem with the popularity
of Morley cigarettes is that when you
see it now in a movie or of a television
show it kind of pulls you out of the
fiction
[Music]